as a men yeah majority of us  at one part of my life myself we are  absolute simps yeah right like and  that's like  girls some girls hands down  and the girls do you like it absolutely  go for those girls but the majority of  the girls they like a simp once you're  in a relationship while you're not in a  relationship as funny as it sounds you  have to be a prick because like the  whole theory of  the nice guy finishes lost comes into  such a major play because of like the  girl needs to feel like  you as a man  if you like get into an argument she  needs to feel like you will tell her sit  down and shut the [ __ ] up  and she would like she would much rather  be some girls will get turned on like  all jokes aside yeah no no all jokes  aside rather than like a girl guy's like  always submitting to like oh yeah she  raises her voice and she's like i've had  this conversation with like girls before  we're like like you tell me  tell me i'm lying right now you know i'm